there's something I take from making  videos that is so satisfying by just  making it about quality and just like  trying to tell the stories that I want  to tell is best as I can possibly tell  them I think yeah during the Vlog period  working seven days a week it was at its  absolute Max you could probably stretch  that rubber band but it was always it  was a pursuit of interestingness that  was just unrelenting everything was fair  game then the depths of my psyche were a  fair game like nothing was off limits  there was no version of myself that I  wouldn't externalize  and that [ __ ] you up I had completely  exhausted who I am it was like kind of  the orange that was my brain I squeezed  every ounce of juice out of it